à la bien qu'il ya un an mais partout au
québec
[Musique]
représente avec les roux directeur des
opérations pour les travaux de
décontamination en est bien plus jeune
on me disait tout le temps que je
manquais ouvrage un jour j'ai jamais
manqué du village pour l'enlèvement des
biens en dessous on a d'ouvragé encore
pour au moins 50 ans nos justes pour
l'enlève les travaux d'enlèvement
d'amiante telbec anomie il y en eut omis
dans les écoles y en eut omis dans les
maisons on omis dans plusieurs produits
on a retrouvé un utile de plancher ne
retrouvait aussi dans les murs de plâtre
really les cloisons les plaques oncle at
on retrouvé de la viande bas les joints
angels aussi qu'ils étaient plus récent
beaucoup d'amiante les halles en amiante
sur la tuyauterie sur les à la mécanique
qui était fait avec à base d'amiante les
salles un coupe-faim pour les structures
d'acier
c'est juste pour vous montrer le style
de costumes jetables 2 les gones devront
porter à l'intérieur des zones
contaminées
ils vont se dévêtir flambant nu à vendre
enfiler la combinaison parce qu'à
l'intérieur va sont contaminés ils vont
enlever l'amiante il ça se peut qu'eads
est faible sur les autres c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'ils vont prendre une
douche avant de sortir on enlevait ils
vont prendre leur douche puis vont fois
à mettre le vêtement de ville
juste pour vous montrer la sorte de
masse que les employés vont utiliser
pour faire les travaux d'enlèvement
d'amiante
si on aime asca ventilation assistée et
puis j'ai aussi un masque style de type
demi masques pour les travaux à risque
faible enlèvement le tulle de plancher
etc
si les choses qui se passent que je
jouais depuis plusieurs années c'est
incompréhensible incomplet ancien coach
fait de job avec les sous que l'espace
puis toute l'équipe et enlève l'amiante
au complet avec la grosse cote combattre
les puits de la bâtisse a couru ce que
le duo a eu des mots liés avec cplp
l'amiante at-on batteur puis dans la rue
puis en cours d'école c'est con mais ce
qu'on peut conditionner ces quatre
personnes qui est pareil qui a personne
qui bloque la csst épaules assez pauvre
elle et les jeunes laissés à ceux ci
comme j'ai dit tantôt sont montrés
responsables envers l'amiante mais il y
en aura pas assez on n'a pas assez pour
le montant du village qui se passe
[Musique]
oh
où
je me nomme gilles mercier j'ai
travaillé pour la csst sénat comme
inspecteur de 1980 à 2000 size me
demander si sida paiement là c'est la
snes fait tout ce qu'il faut pour
prévenir les dangers liés à l'amiante
non moi je trouve que le nombre
d'inspecteurs est insuffisant le domaine
de l'amiante c'est complexe
l'inspecteur est important dans le
processus c'est lui qui va aller
vérifier s'assurer que les mesures de
prévention sont respectées moi mon avis
il devrait y avoir minimalement - un
expert amiante notre région du québec
dans les 20 régions du québec à montréal
il devrait en avoir plusieurs
parce que montréal il ya beaucoup de
chantiers ya beaucoup il ya beaucoup
d'endroits où ou où on est susceptible
de retrouver de l'amiante juste trois
chefs la norme d'exposition québec c'est
une fée par cesser en 2010 est depuis
depuis depuis très longtemps au canada
dans toutes les provinces du canada
car tout cas de la norme d'exposition
les dix fois plus sévère à 0,1 puis
depuis quelques années en france puis
aux pays borde la norme était même
abaissé à point zéro une fille parce
c'est donc on un non-dit fois seul qui
prévaut partout dans le monde si on
dirait qu'au niveau de l'amiante ne sait
quand il faut pas parler cours il faut
garder sa mort s'est passé des choses
que je demande à m'expliquer à
comprendre et à accepter
[Musique]